- [Interviewer] Have you been beaten up,
raped, all that stuff?
- I've been raped so many times
that it's become acceptable.
I think that as long as like
I got out of it, it's okay.
I didn't cry. It's okay.
You'd hurt me that time. It's okay.
- [Interviewer] You are lucky.
Alright, Amber?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Amber,
where'd you grow up?
Where are you from?
- I'm from Los Angeles, California.
And I grew up on the
West side of Los Angeles.
Like, well, they can
pick in the Bria area.
- [Interviewer] You're
working in Figaro street?
- Yeah. I'm currently
working on Figaroa street.
I'm working girl.
And I work in the hundreds.
So that'd be from like 100
first street all the way down
to like, like I said, the 100.
So it goes as far as 150 street,
but yeah that's how I work.
- [Interviewer] Great. And
tell me about your childhood.
You had both your parents growing up?
- Yeah. I grew up with a
mother and father in the house.
Really good living at
first, everything was great.
You know, it's Catholic
school, has the best toys,
best friends and whatever like that.
Then my dad died, he was murdered.
- [Interviewer] At what age?
- I was 12 years old.
- [Interviewer] I'm sorry.
- Oh, thank you.
So when my dad died, everything
just changed dramatically.
Dramatically went from having, you know
Gavin school to having no school.
My mom started using drugs
and she was mourning my dad,
the loss of my dad, is the
only male she'd ever had.
So she took that really hard.
- [Interviewer] So she got depressed?
- Very depressed.
And she went on at that same time,
rock cocaine was just
hitting the scene real heavy.
And she got part of that.
She became a part of that scene.
- [Interviewer] Your family
took the hit really hard?
- Yeah. My first whole
family took the hit,
but everyone in my family used drugs,
but my mom's her drug use was
the worst of all the siblings.
- [Interviewer] And the
kids of course suffer.
- Yeah, of course the kids suffered.
- [Interviewer] You had siblings?
- Yeah there was a younger sister.
She's seven years younger than me.
I don't know if I could see her name.
So I just say she's my younger sister
and I sacrificed everything for her.
Everything.
- [Interviewer] Do you
help support the families?
- Well, what happened is my mom, you know
she started using drugs
and they have these
things called rock houses.
It's where you go in there,
you buy your stuff and you
get to stay on there all,
all day, all night.
So you couldn't stay any
longer and she's do that.
So at first it started off like,
she would leave like $800 in a note,
pay this bill, pay that
bill and get this, get that.
And it went from $800 and
she'd be gone maybe two days.
It went from that to being gone on like,
leaving no money, no
lights, no gas and no, no.
And I had to take care of
my six year old sister.
So I sacrificed my everything for her.
- [Interviewer] So you
just started working
the street at what age?
- Started working at first
day of my first trick,
I like when I was 16,
but I started working the streets heavily
but I got my 18 when I became an adult.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
You can turn to face me if you want.
And so do you work with
a pimp or without a pimp?
- Oh, I have no pimp,
I have a pimp,
It's my drug addiction is my pimp.
You know that that's all
the, all the pimp I need.
My pipeliner you know-
- [Interviewer] That motivates you.
- That's sick gets me up in the morning,
place me down,
yeah, I don't, I don't
follow directions too.
Well, so a pimp wouldn't
be a good thing for me.
- [Interviewer] The crack is your drug?
- Right now, yeah, but I use drugs.
Whatever scene I'm in,
I fit with that scene.
If I'm Crystal Meth or,
you know whatever drug
I wanna please, so I please whoever.
So I then needs are
blended in with your scene,
you know.
- [Interviewer] Did you see
other friends of yours at,
as a teenager that were doing this
for a living and that's
where you got the idea?
- No, I had one friend, an older friend,
she was a couple years older than me.
She was on drugs at that time.
I wasn't using, when I was younger,
she had a friend who needed it,
he needed a young girl and
I was 16 and Needed money.
you know, parents on
drugs, I'll string out
nothing at home, you know?
No food, got a little sister look out for,
and I needed to do at the time.
That's how I looked at it.
- [Interviewer] Did your family
know you were doing this?
- No. They if they know it's only
because they see me outside,
they've never like I've
never come out to my family .
- [Interviewer] To this day?
- To this day.
- [Interviewer] So they
might see this video?
- Yeah they probably,
a lot of people probably see this video.
- [Interviewer] It's almost
like a way of confessing
for a lot of people, I think.
- Yeah. It's a confession,
but it's also like freeing
like lifting 'cause like I've always
wanted my story to be told,
'cause I want like other young
ladies or young men out there
to know if they have a
similar story that, you know,
this is what's gonna happen to you,
If you don't turn left,
if you keep going right,
don't turn left.
It's going to happen to you.
But also just the knowing that, you know,
shit happens to people, you know,
I never once while I was
here to be a drug addict
or and everyone said.
When I graduated high
school, I'm gonna be on drugs
or I'm going to be a hugger, never,
I'm gonna have the
regular goals, you know,
lawyer, doctor, the
things that normal kids,
you know is trying to be.
- [Interviewer] You have those dreams?
- Yeah. I still have those dreams.
I still have college degrees.
I go to school right now.
- [Interviewer] How old are you?
- I'm 45.
- You're 45?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] You look great.
- Thanks.
- Yeah, it's never too late.
- I go to Mount SAC.
We're gonna have a bachelor's degree.
- [Interviewer] I could
totally buy you as a lawyer.
Absolutely.
- I just like people, like,
I just want help people
just want me,
I wanna be a help that no one
was really there to help me.
I want to help, you know,
I got some kids out there in foster care
and they might need my help one day.
Not even know that it's me,
'cause I don't know my children.
So it's some division of a
life that I come across in.
I make a change in some
things you never know.
They might come to embers house,
and that's just my organization, you know
it's there to help because there was not
it wasn't a lot helped when I was younger.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
I think it's times have changed a bit.
- Yeah, it's a good
things had to change up.
Times adapted to there's a
lot of can help the kids.
- [Interviewer] Have you
been arrested for this?
- Oh, I've been arrested twice for this.
First time I was 18,
second and third time
was like last five years,
but I'm probably classified as prostitute,
'cause no violent crimes,
you know, but yeah.
I've been arrested for this three times.
- [Interviewer] Does it
get you down sometimes?
Do you get depressed?
- Oh yeah.
- [Interviewer] It's lifestyle.
- It's depressed every day.
I mean, what was me, you
know, sucks to be me,
but they are depressed every day.
I deal with that.
As long as the fact that I already deal
with that issue in my
life, a mental health issue
it doesn't help that, you know,
I'm up there on the streets.
'Cause I get I get my moments
everyday where I'm like damn, you know
but then I take that hit and
I remember why I'm out there.
- [Interviewer] Despite the way you look,
you dress beautifully and you don't look
like you're working the streets.
You look a little more
like a professional.
I just wonder.
- Yeah. I always think
like you never know how
a family might see you
walking down the street.
I want to at least say, is she working?
Is she not working?
I want you to guess it.
You know, if I am because
one time I saw my son's
father drive down pest street
and I was just like a Hollywood
happy from the seventies.
You know what I mean?
Like everything short little
and the look he gave me
was like such discuss that,
it was like okay,
you can do this but you don't
gotta look like the robot.
Like with the stereotypical
- [Interviewer] You don't
look like the other girls.
- What you can't look like-
- [Interviewer] it's very
obvious what they are doing.
Whereas with you, I'd be like,
no, maybe she's going to home from work.
- Right. I've had that happen to me.
Are you working at work for sure you know,
but yeah I do.
- [Interviewer] Do you feel
like this life has changed you?
You've been doing it for a long time.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] How has it changed?
- It's maybe a little harder
Like, I mean I was very
global as a child, you know
global and believed you, I
believe what you tell me,
I've always believed the
liars, but being out here.
I've learned how to like decipher
the truth from a lie or just
take my own risk with things.
I definitely have become like harder,
like if I care, I do care.
So I can't take that out of away from me.
And that gets me into a lot of
trouble sometimes, you know,
'cause I'm not that fierce
and I don't give damn to kind of woman,
I worry about like,
sometimes you do things,
and I I'm unconscious
kicks in right immediately.
You know, sometimes I do
things and comes and hits in
before I can't even sit down again.
So I recognize those needs, I like that.
I like that I can still look in the mirror
and I still know between right wrong,
'cause I'm that if I stay
out here so much longer,
I'm gonna be like those my friends
are those associates. I
know that are just like,
I cut your throat before
you blink your eye
and I'll take everything you got,
and I don't care if you're
whatever it falls to you.
I need it, I want it, I'm good.
- [Interviewer] Yeah. I've
interviewed some of your
some of those friends like that?
What's the most misunderstood thing
about girls that are working
the streets like this?
- That they're just stories,
they're not just stories,
like a lot of women out here
have suffer from severe trauma, severe,
and they used to start using
drugs and support that habit,
they don't wanna rob you.
I don't wanna rob you,
I don't wanna steal your stuff,
I don't wanna to prison again,
say I've done prison term.
I don't go to prison again.
So I had to figure out
what am I going to do
to support my habit this time?
I then I walked met a street coffee girl.
I never knew what it was.
So accidentally will start
walking down that street.
But yeah, the biggest
misconception is that
we have feelings too, we
still count, you know,
don't she see that man beating
up that girl, you know,
at least pull over and
say, hey care a little bit.
- Yeah. Have you been beaten up, raped,
all that stuff?
- But this is really weird.
So I've been assaulted so many times
and it's just I look at
it as part of the job
you might get paid you might not get paid.
I've been raped so many times
that it's become acceptable.
I think that as long as like
I got out of it, I was okay.
I didn't cry, it's okay.
You'd hurt me that time is okay.
So yeah.
- [Interviewer] It changes what your
line that you'll crosses
- Each time you're assaulted
just takes out a little bit.
And since you have it in you, it takes it,
it chips away at it.
But like I said, you look at
it like as part of the job,
sometimes you get paid,
sometimes you don't.
- [Interviewer] Have
you been in love before?
- Every day.
(both chuckles)
- I'm Julia Roberts,
and I was looking for Richard Gere.
So yes, I'm always in blood.
I always have a boyfriend, always.
- [Interviewer] But your kids.
- I've four.
- [Interviewer] Do you raise them?
No, my oldest he's 13 now,
when I walked away from him,
he was three and a half.
So the other three I've
had on the streets.
So I have set of twins and they're eight,
and my last baby's five.
- And who's raising them?
- The system, in whatever fashion that is,
my twins were born with cerebral palsy.
So being on the streets,
I knew from the beginning
that when they were born with their issue,
that was gonna be able
to take care of them.
You know, if I should
wave to my addiction,
and twins and they're
both having special needs.
So I made a big decision
that to not fight the system.
- When you say they
were born on the streets
meaning the father was
one of your customers?
- No. Well yeah, no not that really.
As I told you I was, I have a boyfriend,
so the father was my boyfriend.
- [Interviewer] Got it.
- But when I'd be on the streets that
I was writing it the
whole time on the street.
- [Interviewer] Yeah. So it's
not a good environment for-
- Not a environment to
have a baby, you know
not to get involved with
to be pregnant every day.
- [Interviewer] So your
story is interesting
'cause your childhood was great
until your dad passed away.
- Yeah.Everything changed.
- [Interviewer] It's
a very different story
than a lot of the girls I've talked to.
Well, Amber, thank you so
much for sharing your story
and good luck with law school
or wherever you go from here.
- Oh thank you.
- [Interviewer] I totally value as a wife.
- Thank you, thank you so much.
- [Interviewer] Thank you.
- Thank you.